Trascrizione: Stefania Recchia
Revisore: Chiara Coletta
Iniziamo il percorso,
iniziamo ovviamente dal Cenacolo,
poco distante da qui.
Siamo nel refettorio
di Santa Maria delle Grazie,
ma ovviamente non parleremo
del Codice da Vinci
né del Cenacolo in sé, ma dell'immaginario,
cioè che cosa è l'immagine.
Porterò un po' l'acqua al mio mulino,
cioè guarderò all'immagine antica.
Questa è la prima immagine di un cenacolo,
fatto in affresco,
completamente diversa da quella
che abbiamo qui a Milano,
forse la prima immagine legata al tema,
che ovviamente è un esempio.
Questo qua è un manoscritto, va bene così,
vedete, è una struttura piatta,
non c'è prospettiva,
Giuda è messo al di qui della tavola,
quindi è un manoscritto
appunto dell'anno Mille.
Abbiamo percorso già un po' di secoli.
Qua è la stessa più o meno cosa,
con Cristo e Giuda ben evidenziato,
in questo appiattimento
stabilito proprio dall'opera.
Questo è straordinario,
questa è una vetrata di Chartres,
in cui vediamo sempre Giuda fuori,
ma Giovanni,
come evangelicamente,
sul costato di Cristo.
Vedete come si evolve l'immaginario
dello stesso passo evangelico.
Questo è Giotto.
Questo è Giotto, che già modifica,
quindi immagina, il testo in modo diverso.
Vediamo sempre Giovanni su Cristo,
e Giuda che intinge.
Abbastanza semplice qui.
Quindi stiamo guardando l'antico,
proprio l'altro ieri.
Questo è Duccio.
Più o meno, a parte la modifica
delle aureole,
una struttura classica diciamo,
cioè viene rappresentato sempre
più o meno nello stesso stile.
Qua iniziamo a cambiare.
Stiamo avvicinandoci al Cenacolo.
Siamo in una grandiosa prospettiva
rinascimentale,
Andrea del Castagno,
appunto ci evidenzia Giuda
sempre all'antico modo medievale,
con Giovanni vicino a Cristo,
però in una prospettiva straordinariamente
rinascimentale
e legata a uno spazio pieno
di gemme e di marmi.
Qua siamo nella Cappella Sistina,
siamo veramente in una sontuosità
non solo di luogo,
ma proprio di idea di spazio,
però su stilemi antichi,
come disposizioni dei protagonisti
di questa vicenda.
Qua invece siamo al nostro,
diciamo, oggetto dei desideri,
che è appunto un po' un lavoro
che stiamo facendo insieme
perché poi ognuno, nell'immagine,
nell'idea,
che si può fare, partiamo da questa,
può essere usata questa immagine,
ma poteva essere usato qualcos'altro.
Ovviamente siamo a Milano,
usiamo uno dei capolavori milanesi.
Ma il gioco è sempre uguale.
Qui, ci sono due cose interessanti,
almeno ci sono tantissime,
ma questo: la spazialità.
Leonardo crea una prospettiva accelerata,
un effetto 3D, che non era mai stato dato,
e magnifico.
Immaginate per un visitatore dell'inizio
del Cinquecento
guardare questa infinità,
che viene ancora resa in gigantesca
da queste tre finestre, verso l'infinito.
Francesco I, quando arrivò a Milano, ha detto:
"Me lo porto a casa". No, un attimo. Ecco.
E soprattutto il tema.
Cioè non parla di tutto quello che succede
in quella santissima notte,
ma, nel refettorio dove tutti i giorni
i domenicani mangiavano,
c'è l'eco delle parole di Cristo:
"Uno di voi mi sta tradendo, mi tradirà".
E c'è proprio una teatralità.
Vedete le mani, vedete questo supporto,
vedete quanto, cosa succede no.
Che è un po' inquietante andare
tutte le volte a mangiare
e vedere questa immagini
che ti evoca qualcos'altro.
Cosa succede dal 1498 ai giorni nostri?
Qua niente.
Siamo nell'inizio, ma siamo in latitudine,
Eh no, ma è importante sapere!
Eh no, perché ovviamente ho portato
esempi non troppo –
come dire, auto-referenziali,
nella dimostrazione.
Però anche al nord
non era ancora arrivato.
Non c'era internet, invece era –
Dürer, che aveva conosciuto Leonardo,
poco dopo,
ovviamente lui è un grandissimo,
non è che lo copia,
però ha già un movimento,
un'apertura, una prospettiva.
Qui Albain, soprattutto nelle mani,
e soprattutto in queste tre aperture,
ovviamente avrà visto qualcosa.
La reinterpreta.
Guardate come viene elaborato
a livello mentale di immagine,
nel corso dei secoli.
Un po' un lavoro che stiamo facendo
adesso.
Non ce la farò mai, ecco.
Abbastanza chiaro il riferimento.
Ognuno poi si trova i particolari,
perché ognuna avrebbe bisogno di –
Qua siamo negli anni Venti
del Cinquecento,
e proprio c'è, guardate le mani,
qua a destra,
la struttura, le tre aperture.
Una cosa ovviamente diversa,
al il richiamo, l'eco.
Questo è un Tiziano prima maniera,
che ha l'apertura, ma abbastanza diverso.
Un Tiziano della maturità,
straordinariamente simile.
Morirà nel '76, ma guardate
il movimento, le mani.
Giovanni lì, però Giuda comunque
è insieme agli altri,
siamo tutti traditori.
Non si può più fare a meno
di questa opprimente
immagine del refettorio
di Santa Maria delle Grazie.
Vedete voi, guardate le aperture dietro.
Non so, un po' copiata.
Non volevo far ridere, ma bene.
Rubens, ovviamente lui è un grande,
qua questo dipinto l'ho messo
per dire che,
si sa benissimo, però, come a dire:
"Ci penso io".
Ci sta.
(Risate)
Questo qua è –
volevo passare una tavola di Parigi –
(Risate)
Qua proprio Philippe de Champaigne,
uno dei miei autori preferiti,
addirittura c'è la piegatura
attiva e passiva
della tovaglia stirata del cenacolo.
Complimenti.
Cioè, meraviglioso.
(Risate)
(Applausi)
Tiepolo invece, ovviamente,
c'è l'apertura nel senso della spazialità,
della commensalità,
però ovviamente diciamo che
ci sono degli aspetti molto vicini
al Cenacolo,
però proprio tra le righe.
Non è questo il luogo per –
Qua proprio siamo nella seconda
metà dell'Ottocento,
Vogliono –
Questa è San Pietroburgo,
i russi vogliono fare una loro
immagine di un testo evangelico ortodosso,
e quindi si distaccano completamente
dal prototipo vinciano, giustamente.
E quindi vi ho portato
anche il contro-esempio,
che male non fa.
Questo è un Nolde.
Non c'è quasi nulla del Cenacolo.
C'è proprio la voglia di rompere
con la classicità,
anche se questo senso
della convivialità rimane.
Però ovviamente qui sarebbe un po' ardito.
Anche quindi l'esercizio è non trovarlo
in ogni momento.
Calma un attimo.
Infatti li ho portati apposta.
Qua è Spencer, che non c'entra nulla.
Ritorna Giovanni sul costato di Cristo,
però c'è l'apertura,
questo senso della tavola,
e non la divisione con Giuda.
Ormai questo prototipo è entrato
anche nella modernità,
nella contemporaneità, la infetta.
E non se ne può fare più a meno.
Dalì che sembra anche lì, ma c'è proprio la –
completamente diverso,
questo senso proprio dell'eucarestia
di cui Leonardo
non voleva dare assolutamente,
ma c'è il senso dell'infinito.
Ovviamente fa sempre un po' –
un po' sopra le righe Dalì,
però ne ha sicuramente un sentore.
Questo è interessante perché è esatto.
Questo Buffet, che è ai Musei Vaticani,
è esattamente un ricordo,
non vuole imitare Leonardo,
imita quello che c'è stato prima:
con Giudas, il cui nome compare in alto,
al di qua della tavola,
come succedeva a Chartres,
come succedeva nei manoscritti
che abbiamo visto.
Guardate questo è un regalo,
questo è un Bunuel,
nel film che ha vinto nel '61
il Festival di Cannes,
visto che siamo recenti dai fasti
della Croisette,
guardate, imita esattamente,
è una celebrazione del Cenacolo
di Leonardo.
Anche l'arte, un'altro tipo di arte,
non ne può fare a meno.
È il cenacolo senza i commensali.
Questo acrilico in cui, ovviamente,
ormai Leonardo diventa il padre
a cui non si riesce più a togliere.
Warrol, che dedica al Cenacolo Da Vinci
proprio una serie
notevolissima, guardate anche questa,
di studi fotografici e di serigrafie
su tela.
Paterson cambia completamente,
la modernità proprio:
una parete con i nomi.
( Risate )
Interessante, ovviamente
non mi sembra –
che ci siano grandi affinità, però –
ma non vogliamo trovarle a tutti i costi.
(Applausi)
Questa, questa che è un po' reverente,
è un cenacolo in cui sembra
che non ci siano affinità,
invece ce ne sono molte:
molte per la divisione degli apostoli,
e per quelle tre aperture.
È inutile, anche se siamo in un sottoscala
in un sobborgo di New York,
ricorda, echeggia,
il refettorio di Santa Maria delle Grazie.
Ne poteva far due, per non essere
proprio uguali!
No tre.
Questa è l'ultima che vi faccio vedere.
È una pubblicità che ovviamente
è dissacrante,
perché ricorda talmente il cenacolo
che ovviamente è stata proibita in Italia
perché considerata blasfema
anche perché pubblicizzava
dei collant francesi.
(Risate)
.
Benissimo.
(Applausi)
Abbiamo finito.
Voi vi siete fatti un po' il filo,
avete visto un po' –
questo è un gioco che potete
fare a casa con gli amici,
mettendo le figurine
e aprendo i libri di storia dell'arte.
Ovviamente è una provocazione,
abbiamo fatto il cenacolo,
ma potevamo fare qualsiasi altra cosa.
È un modo per dirvi diverse cose:
una banalmente che il moderno è leggibile
nella sua completezza
solo se c'è l'antico,
e quindi dobbiamo per forza.
Addirittura andiamo a vedere lo ieri,
ma anche l'altro ieri,
per essere proprio tranquilli e sereni
e prenderlo nella sua interezza.
Un altro discorso interessante
è il discorso degli archetipi.
L'ha affrontato Jung in modo –
Cioè noi viviamo di archetipi,
dentro di noi,
nel nostro pneuma, nella nostra anima
abbiamo degli archetipi,
cioè delle immagini,
che ci rendiamo consapevoli
o non consapevoli.
Ovviamente gli archetipi iniziano
dal mito.
Ma io sto parlando
di archetipi immaginativi,
cioè nella creazione di nuove immagini.
Il Cenacolo è un capolavoro non solo
per la maestria,
per chi l'ha fatto, per la fisiognomica,
per tutto quanto è stato scritto,
ma perché è un archetipo, cioè seduce,
è un'energia, che ovviamente,
a cui si deve per forza fare i conti;
è un padre e un nonno
a cui tutti gli autori,
ma non solo gli autori
che creano l'immagine,
ma noi fruitori abbiamo
un eco di questa immagine.
Il problema, in un mondo
così pieno di immagini,
è difficile creare archetipi nuovi
per il futuro,
perché ovviamente sono stati già fatti,
ma comunque pensiamo a studiare
quelli antichi,
per capire dove possiamo posizionarci.
Perché creare archetipi, è creare
nuovi linguaggi,
nuove comunicazioni.
Un nuovo senso di spazialità mentale,
di libertà interiore.
Al Cenacolo non vediamo
un'immagine fissa su un muro,
ma un'energia, una storia, è una poesia.
Un'ultima cosa.
Qua tiro veramente l'acqua al mio mulino,
onestamente.
Si, parliamo tanto di contemporaneità.
Abbiamo visto quanto serve per il domani,
comprendere l'antico, quasi una banalità,
vi sto dicendo.
Però mi piace pensare che queste pitture,
che questi capolavori,
queste uniche immagini
che non vanno via come internet,
come youtube,
ma rimangono lì fisse
aiutano noi ad arricchirci.
Come diceva Simone Weil,
una grande filosofa del Novecento,
"La bellezza di quelle immagini erode
la mediocrità, la bruttezza".
Un altro autore dell'Ottocento diceva:
“Io non vado nei musei per conoscere
gli antichi maestri,
ma per conoscere meglio me stesso."
Ecco, il messaggio non è partire
dal Cenacolo e fare questa cosa.
Il messaggio è che quelle immagini
servono noi oggi,
a vivere, a superare le difficoltà,
ad andare in un museo
e fermarsi mezz'ora davanti
a un grande quadro
e l'energia di quelle forme,
di quei colori,
di quella sapienza ci aiuta a vivere oggi.
E forse con un animo più sereno
vedremo il futuro.
(Applausi)